[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans sénat stream votre rendez
vous hebdomadaire 2 public sénat on a le
plaisir de recevoir chaque semaine en
sénateurs une sénatrice et cette semaine
j'ai l'immense plaisir de recevoir éric
bocquet éric bocquet sénateur communiste
du nord bonjour bonjour vous allez bien
très bien très bien arriver à bien
installer tout à fait tant mieux on va
passer une heure ensemble on va
apprendre à vous connaître on va faire
votre portrait on va aussi parler de
votre actualité au scénario on va pas de
l'actualité en général
bonjour à vous si vous nous regardez
actuellement sur twitter bonjour à vous
dans le chat c'est bien vos questions
que vous m'avez passé hier que je vais
poser aux sénateurs bonjour à vous si
vous ne regardez également sur public
sénat le canal 13 de la tnt
alors avant de parler de vous éric
bocquet je voudrais quand même qu'on
commence par parler d'un sujet
d'actualité c'est parti pour le moment
actu alors le moment actu aujourd'hui
c'est pas rien on est en train de vivre
un tournant aux états unis on né le 20
janvier mercredi 20 janvier c'est le
jour de la prestation de serment de
l'investiture de joe biden le 46e
président des états unis d'amérique dans
un contexte très particulier puisqu'il
ya seulement deux semaines des
manifestants pro trump ont envahi le
capitole le parlement américain vous
êtes parlementaire comment vous avez
vécu ces images beaucoup de sidération
mais c'est l'aboutissement de quatre
années complètement inédite et
complètement démentiel avec l'élection
d'un président enfin à laquelle personne
ne croyait et tout le déroulement de son
mandat n'a été que l'illustration de ce
qu'on craignait quoi tous les excès tout
tous les populismes qu'il a pu alimenter
et c'est tous ces pratiques au plan
national et au plan international enfin
on a vécu des scènes absolument
inimaginable donc la page se tourne
enfin le président sortant disparaît
mais cela dit je crois que les causes de
cette situation il va voir les traiter
en profondeur
je crois que joe biden un sacré défi
devant lui alors on va on va on va en
parler avant ça j'avais une question de
2 de pretty fly qui voulez vous demander
comment est ce que vous expliquez la
contestation d'un vote démocratique
les contestations des résultats
d'élection c'est quand même pas rien non
mais je crois que dans les soutiens de
trump alors faut quand même dire 74
millions d'américains ont voté pour lui
comme un corps cette fois il y en a
encore plus coté provider mais il ya une
diversité de sensibilité dans cet
électorat mais il ya aussi
on l'a vu dans les images pendant le
mandat et à l'occasion de cette scène d'
attaque sur le capitole il ya aussi une
extrême droite qui a aussi des fascistes
il ya aussi des des radicaux d'extrême
droite qui sont prêts à en venir aux
armes et à l'extrême pour renverser le
pouvoir donc oui c'était très serré très
grave ce qui s'est passé younes qui vous
pose la question est ce que c'est
possible en france ça on peut se poser
la question
on peut se poser la question alors
certains ont fait le parallèle avec les
gilets jaunes c'est pas tout à fait
content c'est une question qui vous est
posée aussi par vous les pieds traquera
mais c'est ça parce que ce qui se passe
quand même dans le monde on vit des
moments difficiles les démocraties sont
sommes sont contestés aujourd'hui de
manière évidente mais je crois que c'est
la résultante de de frustration de
déception accumulée au fil des années
l'aspiration des gens c'est à vivre au
mieux c'est d'avancer vers le progrès
d'échapper aux difficultés à la
précarité au manque d'argent ou mal au
mal logement etc
et à trop d'occasions il ya eu des
déceptions accumulées des gouvernements
ont déçu ici et ailleurs dans le monde
et ça fait grandir la colère alors c'est
une mauvaise réponse que d'aller vers
ces solutions là mais on se trompe de
colère mais moi je souhaite que les
colères soit soit progressiste soit
rouge mais parfois on peut dériver on le
vit en france parfois vers des colères
noires dangereuse et qui peuvent
rappeler parfois les heures les plus
sombres de notre histoire et skander qui
volaient vous de vous vous demandez si
les difficultés des états unis ne sont
pas annonciatrice de difficulté qu'on
aurait nous en europe dans quelques
années si tant est qu'on les ait pas
déjà d'ailleurs en europe
oui je crois qu'on n'est pas tout à fait
étranger à cette crise aux inégalités
qui explosent aux discriminations de
tous genres alors il n'y a pas
d'automatisme selon dit parfois ce qui
se passe aux etats unis arrivent chez
nous dix ou quinze ans plus tard il ya
il n'y a pas d'automaticité on n'a pas
les mêmes histoires mais quand même ça
doit nous interpeller et nous appellent
à la vigilance pour répondre aux
aspirations des gens justement en tant
que vous êtes largement terre vous êtes
sénateur est ce que nos institutions
nous sont plus fortes que les
institutions américaines
ils ont les ont leurs qualités mais
elles ont aussi leurs défauts notamment
le défaut principal que jiwa c'est la
concentration du pouvoir au sommet de
l'état et je crois que ce point de vue
on est gênant ce sentiment qu'on est
arrivé au
au bout de notre vème république il est
temps de passer à autre chose
aujourd'hui bon ça tient la maison tient
entre guillemets mais on n'est pas à
l'abri d'un éclatement je ne sais pas
sous quelle forme je suis pas devin mais
il ya une réponse à apporter aussi en
termes de démocratie dans cette
république à propos de démocratie des
pop man qui qui qui m'avait fait
remarquer qu' on a critiqué le mode de
nomination du président des états unis
et lui indirectement les sénateurs en
france sont élus indirectement oui on a
un peu à un système à direct voilà ce
sont les grands et les stations aussi de
l'élection sénatoriale en france je
pense qu'il faudrait réfléchir un autre
mode de désignation de 1 des sénateurs
je pense je crois d'abord à l'utilité du
sénat et du bicamérisme ça c'est une
certitude et le contexte actuel en
france le démontrent à plusieurs
occasions
voilà leur parlera de ça voilà mais le
mode d'élection des sénateurs absolument
et aujourd'hui on est élu je crois par
cent cinquante mille personnes en france
bon on est légitime mais il faudrait
réfléchir à un autre mode de désignation
des sénateurs et sénatrices
incontestablement j'aurai des questions
pour vous plus tard là dessus sur
l'évolution de la démocratie mais c'est
mais c'est intéressant qu'on commence
d'ores et déjà en parler une question
qui m'a été posée également sur
sur paris elle fait ses pardons qui vous
demandent si l'instabilité des usa et
possiblement dans cette triste aussi
d'une instabilité mondiale on a vu
apparaître on voit apparaître dans le
monde à l'échelle planétaire quand même
bon il ya eu l'élection de trump que
d'aucuns pensent est tout à fait
impossible
on a eu d'élection de bol sonar au
brésil on à erdogan en turquie non
qu'ils étaient nus mais qui posait
problème on a on a des leaders qui sur
kiki sur jez qui surgissent aujourd'hui
et qui ont des méthodes quand même
qu'ils interpellent en termes de
démocratie je parle pas de dictature
mais il ya des régimes très autoritaire
pour dire le moins
on voit surgir des leaders de ce genre
et en france parce que vous commencez à
le dire aussi un peu emmanuel macron lui
aussi at-il les traits d'un autoritaire
en tout cas très verticale très
jupitérien c'est comme ça qu'on le
surnommait le début du quinquennat mais
je crains que tout ça n'a pas disparu
même s'il s'efforce de gommer ce défaut
mais non on a un système très vertical
la constitution renforce ce défaut les
gens n'en peuvent plus quoi le gens ne
se sentent pas écoutés prise en compte
respecter c'est c'est vous êtes
communiste leleu l'impérialisme
américain c'est un truc que vous
combattez oui cet effondrement des états
unis a causé par trump c'est quelque
chose qui vous réjouit un peu
effondrement et des relatif
il ya une question serait démocratie
américaine mais l'économie américaine
domine le monde aujourd'hui on parle des
gars femmes les gars femme qui pèse plus
que des états la puissance financière de
apple est supérieure au pib d'un pays
comme le danemark ou le portugal on peut
se demander où le vrai pouvoir dans le
monde aujourd'hui se trouve alors à ce
sujet là j'ai aussi eu des questions
pour vous à propos du fait que les gars
femmes ont décidé de supprimer le compte
de donald trump et plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de comptes liés aux mouvances
d'extrême droite aux états unis c'est
une bonne chose ou pas alors au premier
la première réaction c'est de dire que
ça fait plaisir qu'on ferme la bouche de
ce gars mais quand même ça pose une
question justement au niveau
démocratique twitter tout seul dans son
coin décide de qui a droit à la parole
tout le monde la majorité des gens
combattait les propos de 30
d'autres les soutenait y compris aux
états unis mais que la décision de
fermer un compte relève d'une entreprise
privée comme cela je dis que ça pose un
problème au niveau juridique au niveau
des mots
pratique les accords bilatéraux entre
les européens entre l'europe et les
etats-unis vont-ils s'améliorer à
l'occasion de l'arrivée de maiden on
sait que biden à l'intention dès
aujourd'hui d'annoncer le retour des
etats-unis dans l'accord de paris par
exemple sur le climat ça c'est une bonne
chose
je disais tout à l'heure que joe biden à
de grands défis à relever au plan
national et au plan international
oui bon qu'il rejoigne l'accord sur le
climat est une bonne chose
trump avait déchiré la feuille c'était
terrible dramatique
voilà il faut que les états unis dans le
soin dans ce dans ce concert là
évidemment ce sont des acteurs
essentiels mais il ya d'autres sujets il
ya le moyen-orient il ya la rivalité
avec la chine il ya cuba aux portes des
états unis toutes ces questions là
doivent être revues il y avait eu des
avancées avec obama certains tricheurs
cuba je pense à cela on est revenu en
arrière avec trump ou y compris sur ces
questions là il va pas chômer quoi il va
pas chômer et mais voilà il va falloir
que les américains le peuple même s'en
mêle pour que ça aille dans le sens
qu'il souhaite peuple très divisée c'est
peu de le dire
et nous les français attendent et des
leçons alors donner des leçons d'unité
nous donnons à la société française est
éclatée vendus on n'a jamais eu autant
d'inégalités on vient passer la barre
des 2 millions d'allocataires du rsa on
vient d'atteindre 10 millions de pauvres
des gens vivant sous le seuil de
pauvreté qui est à 950 euros par mois
notre société effectivement et est
éclatée on l'a constaté à plusieurs
occasions les élections ça se traduit
par l'abstention ça se traduit par des
manifestations du mécontentement du
mal-vivre du mal être
non on n'a pas de leçon à donner on n'a
pas de leçon à donner il ya beaucoup de
questions dans le chat qui sont posés
beaucoup de réactions autour de 2 autour
de ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur
les gaffes les pouvoirs dégâts face à
inquiète par clément ici là on est
actuellement sur twitter est une
plateforme qui appartient à amazon pour
le coup donc ils n'échappent pas du tout
à ces questionnements effectivement
beaucoup de questions se posent sur sur
les pouvoirs de ces géants du numérique
qui qui s'acquitterait potentiellement
comme vous l'avez dire un danger sur la
démocratie
vous pensez la possibilité d'une réforme
de du csa de l'autorité publique qui
pourrait jouer un rôle sur la régulation
des jeux pan et contenus sur internet je
pense qu'une régulation est nécessaire
moi je veux pas jeter à la poubelle
cet outil numérique qui est absolument
fabuleux qui concède une révolution
fantastique mais qui devrait être un
outil d'émancipation humain quand on
pense que google a été créé en 98
facebook 2004 c'est une génération à
peine sa chambre mais le monde
complètement la communication mais pas
seulement
on voit qu'au plan politique aussi
s'appelle on se souvient d'ailleurs qu'à
l'élection de 2016 l'élection de trump
avait été beaucoup permise par
l'utilisateur et rien sur l'aller les
faits et news et cetera je dire on
touche des millions de gens en un
instant et directement dans leur poche
ce que chacun aujourd'hui son terminal
et son portable dans la main donc c'est
même pas à passer par des écrans qui
parle à des millions de gens c'est des
millions de gens en direct un parent
qu'on peut influencer et parfois de la
pire des manières donc qu' il ya besoin
d'une régulation gelé les gars face et
c'est un outil fabuleux c'est
l'intelligence humaine mais il faut que
ça soit régulée fossat soit transparent
et que ça joue uniquement son rôle d'une
petite communication quoi pas de
direction du monde on viendra sur les
questions démocratiques parce que j'ai
encore beaucoup de questions qui vous
ont été posées par les internautes mais
avant j'aimerais qu'on parle de vous et
éric bocquet
c'est le moment du portrait c'est parti
alors éric bocquet
vous êtes aujourd'hui sénateur du nord
vous avez toujours grandi vécu dans le
nord oui je suis né dans le nord j'ai
grandi dans le nord j'ai fait mes études
j'ai travaillé voilà alors à propos des
truites vous avez fait quoi come back
alors j'ai passé le bac en 75 l'année de
mes 18 ans le bac à 4 à l'époque c'était
un bac littéraire avec une dominante
langue étrangère donc je faisais anglais
allemand à l'époque j'ai toujours adoré
les langues étrangères
alors plus tard vous êtes devenu prof
d'anglais c'est votre métier vous
vouliez faire ça quand vous étiez déjà
au lycée
vous avez des dès le collège dès que
j'ai touché à l'anglais ça me plaisait
je savais que j'en ferai mon métier je
suis devenu normalien enfin voilà donc
destiné à être enseignant et après le
bac j'ai suivi la formation imminente
ans après le bac pour devenir professeur
des collèges à l'époque puis géré passer
le capes j'ai repris mes études à
l'université licence capes et je suis
devenu professeur de lycée en anglais
bon et la politique c'est arrivé comment
chez vous alors la politique hors de
famille non si on nous pose souvent la
question c'est que mon frère a été
député longtemps j'ai planqué sur la
dessus votre frère député vous êtes ci a
été député vous êtes sénateur
et ce en mai et en fait non il n'ya pas
d'héritage familial nos pneus
on ne parlait pas politique à la maison
je suis incapable de dire ce que mes
parents votaient on s'était secrets ont
valu d'aller sur la table donc c'est pas
humain chez nous non il y avait la voix
du nord il ya des femmes d'aujourd'hui
il n'y avait pas de qualité moi je suis
venu à l'engagement
comment ça se fait raconter quoi alors à
18 ans voilà l'année des 18 ans majorité
l'année du bac c'est l'année où j'ai
décidé de donner mon sang je voulais
faire des choses oui et puis c'était la
première née de giscard si j'ai pas de
bêtise soit s'absolvant absolument donc
j'avais même plus j'avais pas l'âge de
voter à l'élection présidentielle mais
donc je suis devenu civiquement majeurs
l'année suivante et un nom à ce moment
là encore oui c'est venu après
effectivement et voilà j'ai trouvé un
jour un bulletin d'adhésion au parti
communiste alors j'étais un peu sensible
déjà appuyé même si mes parents
n'étaient pas engagés enfin ma mère
avait toujours ce souci de refuser
l'injustice refuser l'injustice était
son mot d'ordre et avoir droit à sa
dignité
donc je pense que ça a dû le marquer un
peu mon frère étaient déjà engagés avant
moi ça m'a sans doute influencé
incontestablement puis voilà j'ai adhéré
au parti en 75 je suis toujours adhérent
avant lui et cerbère qui voulez vous
demander ce que vous vous intéressiez à
la politique quand vous étiez mineurs
avant vous 18 ans il y avait bavé
l'appétence il ya un questionnement
j'avais voilà je me suis jamais j'avais
suivi la campagne présidentielle de 74
et giscard etc et je découpais des
articles de presse ce sujet
m'intéressait ce sujet m'intéressait
j'avais vraiment un intérêt réel pour
les débats qui se monnaient j'ai donc
j'ai suivi la campagne à travers la
presse ce moment-là et mais j'étais pas
militant l'époque mais j'ai toujours eu
un intérêt sur l'engagement politique au
sens large dans la société
si vous comprenez les jeunes qui
s'engagent aujourd'hui je le souhaite
non seulement je le comprends mais ce
dont on souffre aujourd'hui c'est du
recul de l'engagement quels qu'ils
soient associés tous ces jeunes sont
engagés aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus de
la même manière ils sont capables de se
mobiliser sur des actions
c'est par solidarité besoin de d'aider
les étudiants par exemple
voilà le le contre les violences faites
aux femmes
il ya des actions mais j'ai pas le
sentiment enfin je peux me tromper mais
qui est un engagement dans la durée
aujourd'hui de l'engagement dans la
durée est perçu comme une contrainte
voilà et c'est intéressant de vous poser
la question et me disais tout à l'heure
voilà j'ai adhéré en 75 au parti et j'ai
encore ma carte aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que les jeunes aujourd'hui voient d'un
mauvais oeil sa ou et engagement
rentré au parti aux syndicats à la sauce
ça pendant des années et vous voyez ça
va si on comme si enfin certains
considèrent qu'on perd sa liberté qu'on
n'est plus soi même qu'on peut pas
penser par soi même
moi je pense tout le contraire moi je
suis devenu ce que je suis avec mes
qualités et mes défauts
je le dois à l'école fondamentalement et
à mon engagement au parti communiste où
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses au
contact de militants ouvriers fin des
syndicalistes le monde du travail
moi je vois là j'étais enseignant je ne
sais pas ce que c'était une usine
j'ai appris au contact de tous ces
militants syndicalistes militants
politiques élus on les écoute en lisant
voilà c'est une formation irremplaçable
qui complète parfaitement le formation à
l'école roy et le mode d'action aussi
militante
le parti ça renvoie à l'image de la
diffusion de tracts de la réunion
interminable le soir de choses ou de
manif à la papa si je puis dire que les
jeunes aujourd'hui voient comme des
choses assez inefficace et qui préfèrent
peut-être les opérations coup de poing
les découpes comme beaucoup plus visible
vous voyez mais là comme il faut de la
communication il faut communiquer sur ce
qu'on fait mais faut d'abord faire je
crois les coudes comme les coups de
poing oui ça peut ça permet de marquer
d'attirer l'attention sur un problème
parce qu'on vit une époque où le
l'information s'est démultipliée mais
dans des proportions démentiel ça
n'avait rien à voir avec la il ya 40 ans
mais le coup de com sans suite et
d'action dans la durée je pas le
sentiment que cela puisse changer la
réalité parce que il faut changer la
réalité il faut changer le
fonctionnement de ces sociétés
c'est intéressant on parle aussi d'entre
eux soit la question d'entre eux soit
vous l'impression que ses interventions
dans le chat peut aussi considérer que
que que kate dans un parti c'est n'être
qu avec des personnes d'accord avec soin
pas forcément
bien sûr qu'on est d'accord sur
l'essentiel on est d'accord sur quoi sur
la nécessité de justice sociale sur
l'idée de partage fondamentalement on
nous appelait les partages de l'époque
de l'accident de paris c'est pas un gros
mot moi ça me va bien le partage plus
que jamais les raisons qui m'ont amené à
adhérer au parti communiste 175 sont
toujours là aujourd'hui alors c'est des
questions que j'avais vous posez voilà
eric bocquet votre communisme c'est quoi
c'est quoi la colonne vertébrale de
votre idéologie de votre refus
d'injustice refus des inégalités
deuxième idée refus de la fatalité c'est
bien l'homme avec un grand h l'être
humain qui fait l'histoire l'histoire
n'est pas écrite d'avancé et on n'est
pas au bout de l'histoire parce qu'on
nous a dit on a enterré le communisme
dans les décombres du mur de berlin 89
d'essayer le problème est réglé on en a
finalisé que l'elysée c'est fini non et
on en est là aujourd'hui donc trente ans
plus tard avec cette situation dans le
monde facem il ya de gens qui n'ont même
pas accès à l'eau à l'assainissement à
la santé à l'éducation et jamais on a
produit autant de richesses le pib du
monde c'est 80 mille milliards de
dollars chaque année
on peut pas avec ça crée un monde
solidaire pour tout le monde que vous
répondez un peu à la question de
vénitiens qui voulez-vous demander à une
époque où le communisme a quasiment
disparu par rapport à avant la chute du
mur de berlin comment continuez vous à y
croire le communisme ça reste une belle
idée pour vous absolument c'est pas trop
lié au soviétisme non alors ça a été une
époque
d'ailleurs on l'a payé nous parti
communiste français on a payé notre
retard à prendre distance avec ce qui
s'est passé à l'est un moscou l'urss
cetera
on a pris du retard parce que le parti
communiste français on vient de fêter
son centenaire la conga tour décembre
1920 voilà il ya eu la révolution
d'octobre 1917 donc inévitablement
l'expérience nouvelle c'est là bas que
ça se passait quoi cela dit cela dit les
communisme n'est pas n'est ni à moscou
ni leningrad ni à la vanille à pékin le
communisme le franc il est né en france
et à paris la commune de paris 1 600
française gracchus babeuf george sand
19e siècle avait utilisé le mot
communisme
oui alors après il ya eu une histoire
évidemment il ya eu les erreurs il ya eu
le henné herman donc le retard qu'ont
appris à se distancier de on a commencé
à le faire en 68
quand on a condamné l'invasion de la
tchécoslovaquie par les chars russes à
prague
voilà c'est là où on a commencé vraiment
une rupture nette par rapport à
l'expérience de l'est puis deuxième
erreur en france pour moi erreur
fondamentale c'est toujours facile à
dire après coup programme comprend
comment c'est une erreur stratégique man
une erreur a expliqué vois ça alors
stratégiquement une erreur parce que
c'est laisser croire aux gens qu'on va
tout régler par le haut on écrit un
programme de 150 pages je me suis j'ai
encore un exemplaire à la maison on a
vendu des centaines de milliers de
bouquins et on s'est dit ça y est c'est
bon on va faire le changement par le
haut à l'époque le rapport de force à
gauche n'était pas celui qu'il est
aujourd'hui
d'accord 69 jacques duclos fait 20% des
voix
gaston defferre futur ps 5%
mais 72 signature du programme commun
mitterrand très grand stratège a compris
ce qu'il fallait faire et il a fait la
preuve est ce qu'il avait dit quelques
jours après ses collègues européens
socialistes ce démocrate est dit j'ai
fait la preuve qu'en france on peut
piquer 3 millions de voix aux
communistes
il l'a fait il l'a fait avec les dons
programme commun dans son contenu
oui c'était une autre société 1 mais si
on se passe de la force et de l'appuyer
de l'engagement des gens ça reste un
programme sur le papier sur une étagère
il rentre pas dans la vie il ya eu des
avancées il ya eu des avancées mais le
rêve n'a duré que quelques années quoi
et puis en 83 ans est revenue
l'austérité et au viol tiendra rigueur
voilà il ya toujours il ya un regret
d'avoir partagé le pouvoir quelques avec
les socialistes non
non on analyse les choses lucidement n'y
a pas de regrets ça a permis des
avancées
ça a permis des avancées je dis moi
alors cinq heures cmu enfin façon les
grandes conquêtes sociales ont été le
fait de gouvernements de gauche
progressiste dans ce pays on va pas
refaire l'histoire mais 36 la libération
ou particules nice peser beaucoup la
sécu qui est en mise à mal aujourd'hui
non je ne regrette pas ces expériences
mais il faut comme on dirait c'était un
moment de notre histoire
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'un
rassemblement plus large avec les gens
avec l'engagement des gens ont parlé
d'engagement des jeux et si
indispensable on va en parler d'eux on
va en parler de du rassemblement à
gauche où des rassemblements à gauche
avance à une question de sylla qui
voulez vous demander ce que le parti
communiste se définit comme d'extrême
gauche non marié ou la limite pour ce
budget là ce que le mot de gauche
aujourd'hui est sujet à caution
questionne beaucoup la question de
savoir est ce que le ps est encore de
gauche elle est où la gauche où commence
l'extrême gauche pour vous le ps le pcf
et ouf
à gauche une gauche à gauche moi le mot
extrême gauche savez c'est pour faire le
pendant que l'extrême droite est dans
les débats souvent on rejette les
extraits museau et dangereux voilà on
met deux ados pendant ça je marche pas
là dedans comme s'il y avait une voie
médiane responsable pragmatique réaliste
c'est simple voilà ça je rejette non non
on n'est pas parti de gauche assumer
clairement extrême gauche non ces
voix-là de la gauche de gauche c'est ça
des goules et oui des pockemon qui
voulaient demander une question simple
et direct est ce que jean luc mélenchon
a tué le pcf
je pense pas selon dés la dent on n'a
pas disparu on a des difficultés bon il
ya eu une stratégie a ordonné aux de
l'ania présidentielle où on s'est rallié
à sa candidature qu'on a soutenu terrain
forçant des voix voilà ça n'est pas rien
mais dans la stratégie de jean luc
mélenchon il ya quand même eu des
questionnements quoi je lis on ne
conçoit pas le rassemblement nous
derrière une personne un homme ou une
femme quel qu'il soit c'est pas ça de
rassemblement le rassemblement c'est le
respect de toutes les composantes et la
gauche et diverses dans ce pays
lagos est très diverse on peut y mettre
les écologistes le parti socialiste en
fait partie même s'il ya des nuances
même si oui mais voilà je vous souhaite
pas ce qu'il s'est passé mais
aujourd'hui le contexte n'est plus le
même
et voilà il faut le libéralisme l'a fait
des ravages sur la planète
moi je met en cause directement sur tous
les problèmes qu'on a jamais on a créé
autant de richesses et jamais on a
généré autant d'inégalités et de
pauvreté dans dans cette halle dans ce
monde et y compris enfonce sixième
puissance économique du monde peut pas
accepter ça aucune fatalité à ça quand
une fois ce sont les humains qui font
l'histoire clairement du coup vous
reprocher parce que je reviens du coup
sûr sur cette question d'alliance vous
reprochez d'un certain point de vue
l'alliance avec jean luc mélenchon en
il a été trop solitaire dans sa dans sa
démarche je trouve franc-tireur trop
alors oui il ya eu çà incontestablement
je pense d'ailleurs qu'il ya réfléchi je
pense que le ton qu'il a vendu n'est
plus celui qui la veille à 5 ans
clairement mais ça règle pas tout et je
crois que c'est aussi le produit de nos
institutions ou aujourd'hui l'élection
reine c'est la présidentielle ouais et
ça ça vous énerve
à peine une présidentielle vient
d'intervenir que des gens préparent la
suivante
et entre deux on fait quoi pour changer
les visages a du mal à la gauche ça à
mais terriblement on a cru aussi que en
gros on joue on joue avec le bassin on
joue au basket avec les règles d autre
qu envoyer c'est pas nous règle les
institutions été faite par un système
libéral et tout le respect que j'ai pour
de gaulle mais très pyramidale très
pyramidale il suffit pas de remplacer
les individus au sein des institutions
pour régler et changer fondamentalement
la société ça ne suffira jamais c'est un
moment c'est un outil mais
et ça ne suffit pas à quoi il faut un
engagement massif des populations se
veut pas dire qu'il faut casser la tour
eiffel ça veut dire qu'il faut s'engager
dans les quartiers les usines que les
gens aient des vrais droits et ceux farc
se fasse respecter énormément de
discussion dans le tchat sur le
communisme et c'est extrêmement
intéressant parce que c'est ce que je
vous avais dit à l'antenne que ça génère
des questions et c'est vrai que c'est
absolument passionnant
une question de jean jacques qui voulez
vous demander quelle est la stratégie du
parti communiste pour conquérir la
jeunesse je reviens un peu notre
conversation qu'on avait jusqu'à présent
sur voilà modalités d'engagement un peu
différentes relations entre les parties
un peu difficile pour les jeunes
effectivement qui ont du mal à y voir l'
envie de prendre sa carte l'époque les
prussiens comprends c'est pas le
préalable
ouais pour la prise l'apprendre prendre
la carte c'est pas le comedd comprend
dans une association c'est pas le
préalable à mon avis et c'est sûr que on
est questionné échouent tous les partis
politiques sont questionnés ça pour le
coup c'est pas que le pc peut-être nous
encore plus que les autres mais
effectivement on doit réfléchir à nos
méthodes à la façon qu'on a de
s'adresser aux gens y compris dans notre
langage choix dans nos publications dans
dans nos façons de faire
qu'on soit nous aussi peut-être plus
horizontale parce que voilà on a une
histoire que je ne rejette pas mais on a
eu aussi une structure pyramidale
c'est comme ça à partir de centralisme
démocratique moi quand j'ai adhéré au
parti communiste français à 75 il y
avait dans les statuts du parti
communiste la notion de dictature du
prolétariat
elle a été retirée plus tard il a été
retiré au 22e congrès en 65 années
suivant confiance avait rien j'adhérais
pas un parti dictatorial j'en sais rien
moi je voulais combattre l'injustice et
changer le monde voilà et c'est toujours
vrai aujourd'hui c'est même encore plus
vrai qu'il ya 40 ans
donc oui on doit sans doute réfléchir le
monde a beaucoup changé et la jeunesse a
beaucoup changé
voilà mais la jeunesse aussi à la
spirale aspirent à un monde meilleur
c'est évident elle aspire à avoir sorti
de la précarité parce que la précarité
les jeunes ont par les étudiants en ce
moment on pas des délits vert ou hubert
ça c'est une précarité
institutionnalisée c'est pas ça l'avenir
quoi j'ai deux questions pour vous il ya
une première question qui et comment
expliquez vous que le vote ouvrier se
dirige lentement vers le rassemblement
national
or abstention et une deuxième question
sur le fait une réflexion qu avec
laquelle vous allez probablement être
d'accord qui est de dire le pcf gagne
peut-être pas des adhérents mais les
idées communistes gagne du terrain parmi
les jeux
oui je partage quand je vous dis les
aspirations n'ont pas disparu non les
aspirations n'ont pas disparu qu'elle ne
trouve pas à s'incarner dans un parti d
des élus masculin ou féminin s'est tué
c'est possible c'est une vraie question
mais les idées d'un monde meilleur d'un
plus grand partage de justice sociale de
démocratie de respect de l'environnement
fin tout c'est une aspiration de naturel
de vivre dans un monde meilleur
aujourd'hui on a quand même souvent
l'impression qu'on est dans une espèce
d'impasse et que ce système capitaliste
n'offrent pas la solution d'avenir
on est au bout d'un système alors il n'y
a pas d'automaticité non plus on va pas
basculer un jour dans un monde meilleur
il va falloir le construire nous-mêmes
quoi en étant convaincu que les moyens
financiers existent le faire à la
richesse on va pas vous faire un dessin
mais les on a par l'inégalité on a parlé
des des classes les plus défavorisées
mais du côté de ceux qui ont de l'argent
ça tourne pas mal quoi et donc l'autre
question sur l'électorat ouvrier qui
aurait peut-être un peu déserté leur
vaut pas communiste faut pas se le
cacher on a contesté un moment parce que
c'est nous mêmes et dans ma région mon
ex l'ex-bassin minier on a on a connu ça
alors c'est pas c'est pas fort c'est pas
une adhésion au troisième reich
c'est pas c'est pas des fachos c'est des
gens désespérés et la colère s'exprime
je parlais de colère noire mais elle
s'exprime comme ça c'est une forme de
désespérance l'urgence pour la gauche
c'est de reconstruire une espérance et
j'emploie à dessein le mot espérance un
avenir le le vote front national
aujourd'hui rassemblement national c'est
un vote de rejet d'exclusion alors avec
toutes les raisons que qu'on nous dit
elle
la peur de l'autre la sécurité etc etc
tout ce qui a fait le fonds de commerce
du front national à l'époque qui a peut
être été aussi un moment donné pour des
raisons politiciennes encourager parce
qu'il sert de repoussoir 1 - danny boyer
mais aujourd'hui dans des second tour
d'élection présidentielle
et bien quand on a en face le front
national ou le rassure nationale eh bien
c'est ça permet d'être élu quoi une
question de minutes qui vous demande du
coup est-ce que vous soutenez la volonté
de fabien roussel d'une candidature
autonome du parti communiste en 2022
il a comment dirais-je il est arrivé à
la tête du parti communiste français sur
cette ligne là au congrès y avait des
débats les débats ont toujours lieu
c'est normal c'est la vie mais je pense
que cette question était majoritairement
tranchée par les adhérents les militants
et ctu c'est un vrai sujet encore une
fois c'est pas un discours anti
stratégie qu'on a pu avoir aux deux
élections présidentielles précédentes on
assume mais l'effacement du parti
communiste français n'a pas été une
bonne chose
de la même manière que l'affaiblissement
électorale du parti communiste français
n'a pas été une bonne chose pour les
valeurs de gauche
globalement on n'est pas détenteur de la
vérité tout seul mais on à l'histoire on
a des valeurs on a des idées on a des
propositions et notre affaiblissement
n'a pas contribué à contribuer à
l'affaiblissement globale de la gauche
donc l'entité communiste dans cette
gauche a toute sa place
et voilà il doit doit peser davantage le
mot buzz qui vous demandent est-ce que
ça risque pas de créer une autoroute
pour macro cette division à gauche cette
multiplication des candidatures c'est
savez moi je crois que l'histoire va pas
se régler en 2022
je pense qu'on entre dans une nouvelle
phase de la gauche puisque les comment
les c'est pas les élections qui les
élections qu'une fois c'est un moment
important de la démocratie
mais tous ne passera pas par les
élections le rassemblement qu'on est ce
qu'on aspire la auquel on travaille à la
sab le mans il prendra du temps je pense
qu'on engage une nouvelle phase
caen peut plus raisonner tout à fait
comme avant
l'aspiration et largement partagée
april fool incarner un moment donné bon
il faut participer à des élections mais
c'est un travail de longue haleine et
c'est pas c'est pas des coups de com
c'est du faux qu'est ce qu'on fait de ce
libéralisme qu'est ce qu'on fait de la
domination de la finance
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des injustices
voilà les questions de fond il y avait
une question d'être arrogant le chat qui
vous demandait est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu
un peu une différence entre la france
insoumise et le pcf autour du fait que
selon lui la france a soumis ce serait
un peu plus sur les questions sociétales
comme on les appelle lutte contre les
discriminations là où le pcf serait un
peu plus lutte des classes à l'ancienne
c'est peut-être vrai pour une part je
n'ai pas analysé et fondamentalement ces
choses là mais peut-être qu'on a loupé
dans notre histoire tout à l'heure je
parlais de notre affaiblissement on a
sans doute loupé des rendez-vous dans
l'histoire on l'a vu en 68 par exemple
je suis pas sûr qu'on ait parfaitement
compris ce qui se passait dans ce pays
libération sexuelle des trucs mais voilà
il ya certainement des choses qu'on a
qu'on a manqué parce qu'on avait
effectivement le nez sur domination du
capital partager la richesse qui reste
toujours d'actualité mais on a peut-être
mis de côté 112 c'est une erreur
certaines aspirations qui nous ont
échappés parce que on était sur un autre
logiciel mais voilà on a su évoluer
s'adapter et tout reste à gagner
aujourd'hui quoi on va venir à vous vous
êtes devenu sénateur en 2011 il avança
vous étiez maire de la vire de de la
ville de marky mark et marc marquez ni
sa semence bien marquer autant pour voir
comment ça s'est fait comme on devient
sénateur
alors donc jamais on vous a oui j'ai été
élu conseiller municipal en 1983 dans le
village voilà je suis devenu maire en 95
j'étais candidat sur la liste aux
sénatoriales en 2001 à l'époque c'est
michelle demessine qui était sortante
qui était tête de liste et mes camarades
mes copains m'ont j'étais devenue mère
m'ont sollicité pour être candidat à
l'époque c'était j'étais en cinquième
position alors peut-être en cours de
mandat j'aurais pu accéder à un poste
voilà puisqu'on avait deux élus dans le
nord ça s'est pas fait c'est comme ça
aucun aucun souci et à l'élection
sénatoriale la suivante ils m'ont
proposé de prendre la tête de liste de
notre liste l'humain d'abord on la paie
quand l'appeler comme ça sans m'en
cacher quoi que ce soit le monde connaît
mes idées depuis le début même dans mon
village évidemment on n'a jamais triché
sur rien et voilà je me se trouvait
sénateur en 2011 en septembre 2011
vous avez fait campagne auprès des
grands électeurs vous attardez solution
lui on a fait des multitudes de
déplacement comme le font les collectes
dans les campagnes c'est en bloc mais
c'est pas évident pour tout le monde on
menace on sait qu'une campagne
électorale avec des meetings avec des
diffusions de tracts est énorme c'est
particulier c'est particulier c'est pas
une campagne qui coûte cher même si j'ai
eu du mal à trouver une banque pour
financer ma campagne
elles ont rencontré ça après oui non non
c'est pas une campagne coûte cher il ya
un document et des propositions est allé
courrier et puis surtout du terrain des
visites on prend la voiture pendant
trois quatre mois on prend des
rendez-vous et que les maires et puis on
discute de la difficulté de ce qu'on
porte c'est donc chez oui c'est une
campagne sur un électorat de 5800
personnes dans un département comme le
nord alors racontez moi vous avez besoin
de financer une campagne sénatoriale
aroui depuis je crois que depuis deux
campagnes on doit ouvrir un compte de
campagne obligatoire obligatoire c'est
la loi un compte spécifique dédié à ça
et après bon on apprend à nous on n'a
pas l'argent apporté
donc on fait un emprunt qu'on s'engage
évidemment remboursés puisque c'est
remboursé par l'état ensuite en fonction
du score que vous voilà tout à fait donc
si on dépasse les 5%
on a droit au remboursement ou quelques
mois plus tard et que la fois dernière
j'ai eu du mal à trouver une banque vous
allez pousser des portes de banque
côté client d'une banque depuis 30 ans
dont je pensais que naturellement on
accorderait le prêche était une autre
langue du verseau comment votre banque
perso at il permis la présentation de
votre banque et depuis 30 ans veut dire
au fait je suis candidat aux
sénatoriales assez ça est ce que vous
pourriez m'ouvrir un compte
il était un peu hésitant benneteau n'a
jamais fait ça alors je me renseigne je
comprends que ça soit pas fréquent trois
jours après j'ai eu un coup de fil pour
dire ben non on peut pas faire je me
retourne vers une autre banque la banque
postale pour ne pas les nommer
même réponse je commence à m'inquiéter
parce que pas de cours de campagne
patins parfois compliqué et puis le
hasard a voulu que je rencontre le
responsable régional d'une d'une banque
mutualiste à qui je faisais mon problème
et il m'a donné rendez vous le lendemain
avec le chef d'une agence de mon dos de
ma région mais mon problème était réglé
quoi créée il ya déjà des gens qui font
référence dans le château fait que le
rassemblement national se finance en
russie en partie à cause de ça parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à trouver de
banque vous trouvez ça normal que les
banques ne financent pas les parties
prenantes et c'est une vraie question
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est bayrou qui
porte l idée de la créer une banque
spécifique c'est savez du fonds cette
année la vie publique je suis seulement
parce que il s'agit pas de dépenser des
millions mais il faut quelques moyens si
vous envoyez un document aux 650
communes du nord ça vous coûte 3 4 me
dont on voit donc on les a pas donc oui
c'est important que la démocratie a un
prix
alors il faut que ce soit transparent
justifié on est claire là dessus c'est
clair le compte de campagne il est
déposé il est validé il est contrôlé et
si un problème il est rejeté c'est
normal c'est de l'argent public
mais oui il faut de l'argent pour que la
démocratie fonctionne et donc vous voilà
sénateurs à partir de l'année 2011 on va
parler de votre activité au sénat c'est
l'heure du moment c'est nord
alors vous voilà sénateurs à partir de
2011 et j'ai déjà une question de iam ya
4 qui voulez vous demander comment
voit-il votre rôle est votre mission en
tant que sénateur vous servez à quoi au
sénat alors il ya 2 il ya deux angles
bon le premier gars le travail au sénat
dans l'institution vous êtes membre
d'une commission
vous produisez des rapports vous
interroger le gouvernement vous adresser
des courriers au ministre l'activité ne
comment dirais je n'ai pas n'est pas
fictive elle est tout à fait réelle
vérifiables contrôlable et mesurables et
après l activité dans le département la
circonscription des sénateurs c'est le
département dont vous êtes en lien avec
les élus la joie avec ma collègue michel
guillaume dans le nord on édite
régulièrement un journal qui rend compte
de notre activité
tous les six mois on fait un petit
journal qu'on envoie aux 650 communes du
nord à tous les grands électeurs
ça fait ça fait quatre cinq mille
personnes qui sont informés notre
activité on a mis en place un site
internet
on fait des courriers en tweets ont fait
facebook voilà on est dans son temps
avec des moyens anciens et des moyens
plus modernes et tout ça ça donne de la
visibilité en tout cas on l'espère à
notre activité donc vous faites le lien
avec les territoires vous avez oublié
les fon des mères ou leur posait alors
la vaccination chez toi ça se passe
comment raconte par exemple par exemple
j'ai rendez vous dans deux jours dans
une ville de mon secteur et que le maire
qui est un problème pour l'installation
d'un scanner dans sa ville voilà c'est
des problèmes très concrets de ce genre
ok d'accord au xanax au voulez vous dire
que beaucoup de communistes et de
personnes engagées à gauche sont pour la
suppression du sénat
qu'en pensez vous en tant que sénateur
même le parti communiste un temps fut
favorable la suppression du sénat a
voilà mais c'était une autre époque mais
non moi je suis alors c'est pas ma
boutique que je défends tout à l'heure
je parlais de bicamérisme c'est une
réalité c'est moi ce serait à moi alors
c'est quoi cette nécessité nécessité
d'un équilibre des pouvoirs on est déjà
dans une constitution qui concentrent
trop les pouvoirs au sommet de l'état
présent de la république en plus y'a eu
inversion du quinquennat deux versions
de calendrier électoral réduction au
quinquennat du mandat présidentiel
donc en gros vous avez un président élu
et légitime mais après il ya une
majorité quasi mécanique six semaines
plus tard les gens ont du bon sens on
élit un président ou une présidente on
va lui donner une majorité pour
mettre en oeuvre le programme pour
lequel il a été élu voilà donc déjà il
ya déjà ne comment dirais-je une espèce
de fusion entre exécutif et législatif
sur une partie avec l'assemblée
nationale donc s'il n'y a pas un sénat
ailleurs un contre-pouvoir
et puis on l'a vu sur la sphère benalla
par exemple sur voilà le sénat est une
entité autonome libre indépendante
moi je crois que c'est nécessaire à
l'équilibré des pouvoirs et puis c'est
la représentation des territoires aussi
des collectivités des communes sauce à
la mode qui dit équilibre des pouvoirs
mais l'assemblée gagne à la fin
du coup je vois pas l'intérêt dans les
constitutions oui c'est vrai que quand
il ya un désaccord quand on a avec la
classe et mp20 la commission mixte
paritaire qu'il n'y a pas eu d'accord
entre le sénat l'assemblée
effectivement la dernier mot revient à
l'assemblée quand il faut trancher
donc ça veut dire au pouvoir central au
pouvoir élyséen points pourquoi quoi
sert le sénat
il faut il faut il faut redonner du
poids au sénat il faut sans doute
réformer la constitution pour donner
davantage de poids incontestable vous
avez vu la crise en italie actuellement
non en italie à une crise puis en italie
le système est différent en france et le
gouvernement doit obligatoirement avoir
aussi une majorité au sénat ouais et
donc c'est absolument impossible de
constituer une majorité ça fait des
crises d crise de régime en permanence
pensé que ce serait bien en france à
voir c'est pas le bon moment pour poser
des questions mais que voilà le sénat
doit donner son aval pour pour le
gouvernement vote de confiance enfin il
ya une réflexion à mener en tout cas moi
je ne suis pas constitutionnaliste mais
il faut revoir de fond en comble et de
nos institutions et le sénat en fait
partie qui dit ce qu'ils voulaient vous
demander cette image du sénat comme une
chambre réac pour protéger le statu quo
est elle encore pertinente
on en parlait tout à l'heure aux
antennes non c'est une image truquée ou
malveillants non franchement le sénat
était vue comme une assemblée de
d'octogénaires ventripotent assoupi et
de droite est majoritairement de droite
franchement c'est pas ça
ces femmes j'ai vu que les gens on
reçoit des visites régulièrement au cdh
a donné lieu de la région des amis et
qui mesurent concrètement comment ça
fonctionne les commissions le la séance
et c'est l'émission d'information pas
toutes ses activités toute cette
production de rapports d'ailleurs dont
on souligne générale la qualité au
niveau universitaire c'est une mine
d'infos pour le pour la république pour
la population donc il ya un travail
énorme qui fournit au sénat non c'est
une image un peu dépassée alors
peut-être vrai à une époque quelques
décennies mais ça a considérablement
évolué ces dernières années à mon avis
ça s'est rajeuni et dynamisé
incontestablement l'image du sénat a
changé j'en suis convaincu
dans l'opinion voilà il ya sans doute
des progrès à faire c'est un personne
n'est parfait et encore une fois il faut
redonner du poids et du vrai pouvoir à
ce sénat mlr qui voulez vous demander
votre avis sur l'introduction d'une dose
de proportionnelle pour les élections
législatives c'était une idée du
président de la république qu'il a voulu
propres promouvoir depuis quelques jours
apparemment le gouvernement a l'air de
changer de fusil d'épaulé j'ai
l'impression oui mais où
moi je crois quand même à l'aca n'est
pas sans défaut mais la proportionnelle
c'est quand même la justesse quoi vous
peser 25% des voix vous avez 25 % des
sièges c'est arithmétique c'est
mécanique c'est simple ça s'est fait aux
élections régionales par exemple voilà
il faut réfléchir faut aller vers ça
autrement tout autre système alors on
nous dit oui mais c'est compliqué parce
qu'après on a du mal à construire des
majorités
il faut qu'ils aient majorité de
programmes des majorités d'idées poids
ça c'est possible au parlement européen
ça ça fonctionne comme ça il ya les
majorités d'idées parce qu'il ya une
diversité des groupes mais plus
automatique
voilà il ya des majorités qui se dégage
voilà on peut réfléchir
voilà il faut réfléchir à ça pour autant
le scrutin majoritaire comme on
l'appelle aujourd'hui par opposition au
scrutin proportionnel permet aussi de
bloquer si je puis dire l'entrée du
rassemblement national aussi mais ça
c'était l'argument mais ça va on fait
pas tomber la fièvre en cassant le
thermomètre quoi le problème il est là
pourquoi il ya un rassemblement national
pourquoi il ya un tel rejet une telle
désespérance
il faut s'attaquer aux causes quoi ça ne
naît pas sur mars c'est dans notre
société que ça n'est tout ça il faut
répondre aux aspirations des gens enfin
je suis en et base de justice sociale de
démocratie ingold voulez vous vous
demandez si vous deviez changer un point
dans la constitution de la vème ce
serait lequel
et pourquoi un point empêché que le
président de la république et le pouvoir
de dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
intéressant ça retrait du pouvoir de
dissolution ça changerait quelque chose
basse à réduire est considérablement le
pouvoir d'un seul homme ou d'une seule
femme qui a qui pourraient ainsi
dissoudre une assemblée seul parce que
ça lui convient pas et c on sait que
cela aiderait les députés la réplique en
marche à se rebeller on peut peut-être
parce que c'est quand même une arme
effectivement pour mater une majorité un
peu rebelle
et pour ça on menace de la dissolution
donc on instrumentalise un peu ça c'est
non je crois qu'il y avait une mesure à
prendre moi je commencerai par celle là
pour diminuer le pouvoir du président
qui est vraiment démentiel aujourd'hui
john le chauve vous demande quelle
influence à la pandémie actuelle sur le
futur de la delà de la démocratie est ce
que le vote par correspondance par
exemple c'est quelque chose que vous
voudriez développer en france la
visioconférence de l'assemblée au sénat
s'est introduit la démocratie est
confiné bon c'est tout mais on vit une
envie une pandémie historiques inédites
on a tous ça à gérer ça fait
pratiquement un an maintenant qu'on va
être en visioconférence à la commission
au sénat
enfin tout le monde fonctionne comme ça
ça va un moment quoi mais là tout le
monde convient convient à dire que c'est
il manque qui manque d'interactivité on
a l'info on peut dire les choses on peut
entendre ce que l'autre dit mais
franchement 30 être sur un écran ça vaut
pas 30 tête dans une salle où on peut
réagir quoi interagir
c'est bon c'est un mauvais moment à
passer j'espère mais la démocratie
souffre en ce moment aussi le parlement
ait pas beaucoup associé d'ailleurs à
tous quel regard portez vous sur les
innovations démocratique récente par
exemple le tirage au sort de la
convention citoyenne c'est bien ça où
l'alors alors vous tiré au sort vous
tiré au sort 35 trobe alors non on en
attend des cadeaux choisis à tirage au
sort des 35 citoyens pour la politique
vaccinale mais avant ça il ya eu les 150
citoyens tirés au sort pour la
convention citoyenne pour le climat en
l'occurrence ce corps non mais si vous
en pensez de ça moi je préfère
l'élection l'élection ça veut dire
choisir et choisir sur la base d'un
débat démocratique équilibré etc
les gens choisissent et puis après les
lui il a des comptes à rendre à ceux qui
l'ont élu à la nation s'ils me tirée au
sort bon c'est bien
m'enfin c'est pas mal c'est pas la
loterie quoi la démocratie c'est pas la
nôtre il ya sans doute des gens
extrêmement c'est pas prenne de
compétences puis après qu'est ce qu'on
fait de ces 150 citoyens tirés au sort
il proposait sol extrêmement
intéressante il ya quatre mesures
d'emblée qu'ils sont retirés par macron
parce que ça lui convient pas taxation
des dividendes non ça ne fait pas ça la
démocratie les îles et lui rendais
compte donc assez voilà d'accord mais
qu'est ce c'est 150 citoyens on s'assoit
comme ça sur leurs propositions
donc voyez ça règle pas tout coin moi je
sa règle pas tout je crois à l'élection
je crois à la démocratie que chacun pèse
du poids qu'il pèse et chacun a le droit
de s'exprimer
absolument mais le tirage au sort c'est
la fin la démocratie jan vous savez éric
bocquet ça fait deux ans et demi que je
reçois des sénateurs avec plaisir ici le
mercredi dans ce canapé
oui je vous ai tous toutes et tous
sentis perturbé par ce tirage au sort
des citoyens tirés au sort
je veux vous sentez concurrencer dans
votre intimité non non non non c'est pas
c'est pas une question de chapelle et de
loriol pas du tout c'est une conception
de la démocratie et correspondre aux
aspirations dont on parlait tout à
l'heure sur la crise de la démocratie
les citoyens qui veulent autre chose oui
mais la réponse n'est pas le tirage au
sort
sincèrement il faut changer les règles
du jeu changer le mode d'élection des
sénateurs il faut sans doute y réfléchit
c'est clair pour avoir une meilleure
assise encore mais l'élection c'est un
contrat tu as des comptes à rendre à mon
rang jeter et luttait les comptes à
rendre
qu'est ce que tu fais tu sais pourquoi
tu as fait ça un tirage au sort oui mon
et puis au nom de qui on parle de soi
même même si on est brillant même si on
est performant pertinents non c'est pas
mal c'est pas ma conception la
démocratie vince vais vous voulez vous
demander votre position sur le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
lerrick réclamé par les gilets jaunes
il ya une idée derrière ça qui vous
intéressent l'idée de les citoyens
puissent déclencher ou même un
référendum
oui ça me choque pas du tout ça alors
c'est pas de manière systématique quoi
je veux dire on va pas faire un
référendum sur tous les sujets
tous les quinze jours mais sur des
sujets de fond moi je pense c'est une
bonne chose et ça peut redynamiser le
démocratie notre république
qui en a besoin non ça se j'ai eu des
échanges d'ailleurs dans la rue en face
du sénat avec des gilets jaunes qui
passaient par hasard on s'est croisé par
hasard et on a échangé pendant une heure
un peu comme ici avec un facebook live
up est alors intéressant alors qu'est-ce
qui vous disent eh ben il poser toutes
ces questions là qu'est ce que vous
pensez du riz que pensez vous que le
sénat est encore une utilité
combien vous gagnez voyez on a évacué
aucune question comme ça à brûle
pourpoint sur le fond noir dans la rue
j'ai trouvé ça très sympa on a en a des
comptes à rendre
on a des comptes à on ya pas de soucis
avec sa transparence à des trains c'est
une obligation c'est un impératif
on sentait que le mouvement des jeunes à
changer quelque chose dans le rapport au
politique il a exprimé parce que la
défiance aux politiques s'est exprimé à
la de manière spectaculaire mais elle
est ancienne
un orage et les élus globalement c'est
pas ça date pas d'il ya 10 à 2 ans le
mouvement des gilets jaunes a été le
l'expression sous une forme
spectaculaire de ce2 c'est l'un des
malaises c'est ce à quoi on nous écoute
pas un
et justement les gilet jaune disait
comme nous on peut le dire établi celi
et sauf et mettez fin aux paradis
fiscaux quoi moi quand j'ai vu ça sur
les banderoles et gilet jaune
j'ai applaudi alors on est en train d'en
parler justement de la justice fiscale
ça tombe bien je voulais vous en parlez
éric bocquet vous êtes un sénateur et un
militant engagé sur la question de la
justice fiscale
vous avez écrit un livre en 2010 en 2017
qui s'appelle sans domicile fisc et vous
plaidé pour une coopération en matière
fiscale sous l'égide notamment des
nations unies voilà pouvez nous en
parler en fait cette proposition de quoi
lasser effectivement on a publié un
bouquin
mon frère est un journaliste un ami
en 2016 et la proposition phare dans
dans ce bouquin c'est de mettre en place
une coop de la fiscalité de la finance
mondiale à l'instar de ce qui s'est fait
pour le climat en décembre 2015
voilà c'est la géniale autour de la
table c'est à dire que la finance
mondiale et les paradis fiscaux
ça peut pas être géré par un g8 par un
g20
il faut que tout le monde s'y mettre
parce que tout le monde est pénalisé par
sa il ya pratiquement 200 pays dans le
monde et bien tout le monde doit avoir
voix au chapitre et donc on avait
proposé symboliquement que cette coop se
tiennent
bujumbura la capitale du burundi qui est
le pays qui est le pib le plus faible au
monde et symboliquement voilà c'est un
peu un clin d'oeil mais c'était ça tous
concernés tous impacter tous victimes de
l'évasion fiscale 64 milliards par an
pour la france milliards dans l'union
européenne et à l'échelle mondiale ses 8
% du pib mondial
voyez donc là il ya les ressources tout
régler nos problèmes
d'accord réduc var adore voulez-vous
demander est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'être entendu ne serait ce
qu'un peu sur cette justice fiscale un
nouveau bateau est un peu mais encore le
sujet un peu un peu grimper dans les
espionner dans un état absolument
absolument moi je suis donc un militant
maintenant assez ancien je connaissais
l'expression paradis fiscaux mais il
voyait ça voilà du sable blanc et les
cocotiers à huit mille bornes d'ici et
puis non et puis dont on a la suisse on
a luxembourg on à jersey et près du
cotentin là et j'ai découvert
l'immensité de ce réseau de ce système
effectivement vous avez raison le sujet
s'impose régulièrement il ya eu des
scandales des révélations luc slicks ubs
cahuzac tout ça a permis que le sujet de
s'imposer dans le débat public mais tout
n'est pas réglé loin s'en faut on est au
début de prise de conscience
maintenant il faut passer aux prises
objet alors voilà il ya des choses qui
avancent c'était ma question suivante
alors est ce que les choses qui avancent
dans la législation et une volonté de la
part de l'union européenne contre les
paradis fiscaux on va citer madame et
verse naguère et commissaire danoise qui
est très allants sur le sujet alors
qu'ils se heurtent évidemment au lobby
au monde de la finance qui est puissant
j'en parlais tout à l'heure mais oui il
ya une volonté qui s'exprime un peu ici
et là on a eu l'occasion de rencontrer
des gens comme michel barnier qui n'est
pas notre sensibilité
il dit des choses extrêmement étagères
d'adieu émissaires européens et qu'elle
maintient que je sais européen qui était
chargé de l'aviation sur l'aubrac site
effectivement homme de droite on peut le
dire se l'est dit lui aussi comme vers
tiger d'ailleurs foncé sensible à tout à
fait parce que ces voix là c'est une
question de c'est un sujet trans
partisan ça c'est insupportable que des
puissances de ce niveau se soustrait à
l'impôt qui est on a cité henri
morgenthau qui était le secrétaire
d'état au trésor américain dans les
années 30 avec roosevelt disait l'impôt
c'est le prix à payer pour vivre dans un
monde civilisé
mais c'est ça c'est ça l'impôt sans
l'impôt il n'y a pas d'éducation n'y a
pas de sécu il n'y a pas de route ya pas
de collectivités en france
voilà c'est à ça que ça sert après faut
qu'ils soient justes équitablement
répartis et puis troisième et des
conditions évidemment pour qu'il y ait
consentement que personne n'y échappe
c'est notre combat c'est une question
une question qui met aussi beaucoup
revenus notamment celle de mes voeux qui
vous demander ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression que le gouvernement ne
gouvernants sont un peu en train de se
réveiller et de découvrir qu'il ya des
secteurs entiers stratégie qu'il faut
protéger on apprend même que le ministre
s'est ainsi opposé au rachat de
carrefour ont nationalisé stx à saint
nazaire il ya un espèce de
protectionnisme qui est découvert à
cause d'une pandémie
oui oui ça a eu l'effet d'un révélateur
à la après il faudra au delà des paroles
faudra prendre des décisions
effectivement on se souvient des
premiers discours du président macron au
printemps au premier confinement voilà
le monde après ne sera plus celui
d'avant bon très vite le monde après est
revenu à la surface - les dividendes de
l'argent tout ça n'a pas cessé et donc
il faut oui la remise en question se
pose plus qu'avant encore mais il faut
dépasser mes paroles maintenant faut
effectivement agir c'est le système
qu'il faut changer je pense pas que mes
schémas kron et cette volonté à une
question qui revient dans le chat et
elle m'avait déjà été posée hier
effectivement débat qui faut-il annuler
la dette qu'encore non mais quand
emmanuel macron dit quoi qu'il en coûte
l'état viendra au secours de l'économie
pourrait empêcher que tout s'effondre
très bien cette dette la con en train de
contracter la shema qu'on disait
effectivement quoi qu'il en coûte
en gros et me bruno le maire avait dit
vous êtes en argent on va vous en donner
a pas de souci et puis là on vient de
mettre en place une commission au mois
de décembre
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais c'est
monsieur jean arthuis ancien ministre
ancien sénateur un homme très aimable
mais il va présider une commission
composée de dix personnes qui doit
rendre un rapport en fin février en
disant que en gros c'est tout le monde
qui va payer la dette quoi je suis prêt
je prends le pari de donner dès
maintenant les conclusions de cette
commission avant même qu'elle se
réunisse je vous dise qu'ils vont nous
dire a dit toi
la france vit au dessus de ses moyens on
ne peut pas endetté nos petits enfants
il faut absolument réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires
il faut réduire la dépense publique
oui et puis nous devons tenir nos
engagements européens
voilà je prends le pari on verra fin
février qu'est ce qu'il y aura dans le
rapport ça sera ça mais attendez la
dette la dette
il faut l'annuler c'est à dire
aujourd'hui moi il faut qu'on m'explique
là le gouvernement a fait le choix il
fallait mettre de l'argent dans
l'économie parce que j'allais tous tout
s'écroulait mais nous on disait ben il
faut rétablir les essais faut taxer les
dividendes il faut les patrimoines les
gaffes à faut y aller ils peuvent payer
solidarité de ces injustices dit non non
non non hors de question qu'on touche à
l'impôt on va utiliser la dette alors
que les mêmes il ya un an avant le
budget 2020 disait attention le déficit
va approcher 100 % du pib
c'est là c'est le cataclysme aujourd'hui
on est à 120 pour que l'ambiance à
l'ambiance a changé en rien
enfin moi tout ça a explosé les 3% de
déficit de 60 % d'endettement tout a
explosé
donc par la force des choses on a changé
les règles du jeu c'est parce que les
autres ont changé les règles du jeu on
va pas se mentir le la droite allemande
a aussi un d'affaires virage à 180° le
monde entier le monde entier est
confronté à ce truc quoi ils s'arrêtent
john on appuie sur un bouton tout
s'arrête il faut continuer à vivre mais
il faut qu'on m'explique si vous avez
découvert à la banque vous aurez du mal
à voir un prêt va au directeur vous
devez changer de voiture ce direct à une
fois de 15000 euros
oui mais vous avez un petit découvert je
peux pas vous prêtez monsieur et nous la
france on est à découvert depuis 1975 le
dernier budget équilibré de la france 74
depuis déficit déficit déficit
aujourd'hui on est rendu à 2700
milliards de dettes et on arrive
emprunter
un taux négatif connaissez une banque où
vous avez un découvert ils vont vous
prêter à taux négatifs et on y roule
alors et alors ça c'est le premier sujet
de deuxième sujet que c'est que ce sont
les marchés financiers qui financent les
états c'est le privé les fonds de
pension les fonds d'investissement les
grandes banques les assureurs
j'ai beaucoup d'argent est donc prête
aux états y compris à taux négatifs la
dette française on se l'arrachent
si on était au bord du cataclysme si on
était le malade qu'on dit penser que les
marchés financiers nous prêterait dire
qu'en gros et ça peut changer
oui on nous dit on nous dit maintenant
des cils et aussi les torts et aux gros
ça va vous coûter cher mais qui va oser
dire aujourd'hui que on va venir à bout
de cette dette qui va le dire j'y
croyais et vous non cette dette n'a
aucun sens la banque centrale européenne
alors elle a même comment dirais-je
elle a outrepassé ses règles la vicieuse
elle a pris alors on appelait ça dans le
jargon de l'assouplissement quantitatif
des mesures non conventionnelles en
jargon des financiers ça s'appelle comme
ça ça veut dire qu'elle a fait des trucs
pour lesquelles elle n'a pas été
construite quattro du monde merveilleux
elle détient je crois 25 % de la dette
des états l'union européenne vont lui la
bce c'est pas une banque privée
ces banques centrales c'est une banque
centrale c'est vous c'est moi c'est tout
le monde
la banque centrale s'est nous commençons
par annuler les 25% que la bce détient
des titres de dette des états l'union
européenne
ça va alléger notre charge et ça va ça
ne va léser aucun créancier
il n'ya pas d'actionnaire à la bce il
n'y a pas de créanciers
c'est elle qui crée l'argent on crée de
l'argent ex nihilo
comme on dit en latin à partir de rien
c'est ce que fait une banque vous
demander un prêt à la banque vous
n'allez pas voir les 15000 euros dans
votre poche son billet on va mettre
voilà monsieur m'a scié on met un
chiffre de 15 milles devant votre nom et
c'est vous tous les mois qui allait
apporter la relaxation ont été
remboursés oui donc c'est un peu bizarre
comme système et ont des dents ainsi
c'est parce que c'est au nom de la dette
depuis trente ans qu'on nous explique
qu'il faut fermer des lits d'hôpitaux
qui a trop d'enseignants quatre hauts
fonctionnaires que les collectivités
dépensent trop etc
c'est au nom de cette dette qu'on à
imposer l'austérité au peuple pas qu'en
france depuis trop d'années quoi il n'y
a pas d'issue même temps enfin
l'endettement nous rend dépendants des
gens qui nous prêtent de l'argent donc
des marchés financiers qu'est ce que
vous faites de l'argument qui consiste à
dire mais moi on emprunte mois on a
besoin d'emprunter l'un dépendant des
marchés la dette c'est pas un scandale
en soi si c'est pour investir
voilà si c'est pour les privés pour
investir c'est un peu dommage quand même
réduit non mais on est on est sous la
tutelle des marchés financiers moi je le
dis tranquillement alors le pouvoir
politique par rapport à ça il est où le
pouvoir politique c'est celui qui paie
les musiciens qui choisit la musique en
gros oui du coup c'est les marchés font
alors c'est les marchés financiers qui
nous disent attendez il ya trop de
fonctionnaires chez vous 35 heures c'est
pas terrible
l'âge de la retraite il faut le recul
est donc briller les réformes
structurelles et donc réduire les
déficits permet aussi de se rendre moins
dépendant de ses prêteurs et pourquoi on
serait pas financée par pourquoi les
parcs des français là on dit les
français ont épargné beaucoup par la
force des choses on parle de 100 120
milliard pour quoi on mettrait pas en
jeu l édition baptisée l'epargne pour le
financement du logement social pour en
partie mais les japonais détiennent je
crois 95% de leur dette
ouais ça change des choses ça change
tout alors qu'ils pas que c'est la
réponse pc une des réponses les pins des
français comme on peut pas la solliciter
et puis pourquoi parce que alors on va
pas remonter à mathusalem et avancer la
banque de france qui financent l état
français est traité de maastricht 92 a
interdit aux gens que c'est l'article
123 a interdit à la banque centrale de
financer directement les états et
aujourd'hui compte tenu de cette
situation inédite
de fait elle détient une partie de notre
dette parce qu'il ya pas le choix il
fallait faire voyez donc que et puis
dernière chose j'ai vu quand 53 alors ça
remonte un peu le 27 février 1953
l'allemagne a bénéficié de la part de
ses créanciers réunis à londres à
l'occasion d'une conférence de 60%
d'effacement de sa dette 60% de la dette
allemande att a été effacée en février
53 parce que c'était huit ans après la
guerre l'allemagne était complètement
ratée ques les contextes et ruiné il
fallait reconstruire l'allemagne tant
mieux pour le peuple allemand tant mieux
mais une décision a été prise un jour
de passer l'épongé soit 60% de cette
dette donc c'est un choix politique la
dette c'est pas un sujet financier
administratif et technique
c'est une question politique le débat va
monter dans les mois qui viennent et
c'est une très bonne chose
dernière question pour vous éric bocquet
une question de jean dolent coeur
comment est ce que vous voyez l'avenir
de la jeunesse étudiante
vu son état actuel de précarité et de
détresse psychologique travail à
l'urgence effectivement ça alors là
aussi ça a été aggravée par la pandémie
mais déjà avant avant cette pandémie on
a vu ouvrir dans l'est dans les facs ddd
permanents jusqu'au populaire des
épiceries solidaires pour manger quoi on
a vu beaucoup d'étudiants avoir du mal à
se loger donc la situation était déjà
difficile avec des inégalités là
l'urgence effectivement c'est pas une
allocation jeunesse pour leur donner à
manger parce que aujourd'hui
et puis la dignité aussi hein c'est pas
l'aumône c'est leur permettre de vivre à
peu près décemment dans l'eure dans
leurs études parce que forcément avec la
crise économique ceux qui avaient des
petits boulots pour financer des études
malheureusement ils ne l'ont pas ceux
qui sont isolés et iliad a qui laisse
tomber les études ça va faire des dégâts
et puis des dégâts psychologiques
importants on a eu quelques drames
malheureusement donc il ya une urgence
et une urgence a décrété alors on parle
du rsa jeunes 18-25 ans pourquoi pas ça
peut être ça la réponse une allocation
jeunesse autonomie on avait porté sa
intense et une proposition qu'il chaude
actualité
il ya urgence en la matière c'est des
millions de jeunes qui se posent la
question sérieuse et de manière urgente
merci eric bocquet sénateur communiste
du nord d'avoir répondu à mes questions
à vos questions merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cette émission c'est la fin de
sénace trim je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine sur public sénat ciao
[Musique]